top YouTuber Jimmy Donaldson or is
otherwise called Mr Beast I got why you
changed the name Jimmy Donaldson just
doesn't have a ring to it he created a
fast food business known as Mr Beast
burgers and it went tits up the reason
being is that the resulting burgers that
were created by the company he went into
business with shut it on your market
research I tried one
tasted like ass but not in a good way
and now for what some will describe as a
sad story Remy lucidi the French dared
devil who would regularly claim
skyscrapers has fallen from one and died
could have been worse he could have
tried one of those Mr Beast Burgers they
were shocking
[Music]